wen et collard mais moi j'avais juste
une question vous attendait ce moment
depuis très longtemps en réalité parce
que vous avez tenté des sorties dans le
journal qui vous ont été reprochés là là
on a l'impression que vous avez jamais
été aussi heureux mais ça et ça fait
longtemps vous attendiez ce qu'en dit
moi j'y suis tout simplement parce que
nous on ne savait pas longtemps que
j'attendais ce rendez vous j'ai été
passionné par le 13h jusqu'au bout et
c'est vrai que depuis six mois avec
l'aide de nathalie on avait décidé que
je partais enfin six mois avant mon
arrêt donc je me le suis mis dans la
tête après j'avais là dedans donc en
finir bon bien des joueurs a été très
émouvant le passage de témoin avec marie
sauf si on avait tous les deux les
larmes aux yeux à la fin j'ai tenu à ce
que celles qui disent au revoir c'était
son journal quand je suis parti et c'est
vrai qu'elle a des audiences formidable
depuis trois semaines maintenant donc 14
justement on a fait un petit comparatif
entre les deux jt entre le tien et celui
de marie sophie regarder et puis celle
ci janvier le jour de l'épiphanie déjà
dans beaucoup de familles on a tiré les
rois ce week end ce 6 janvier
surtout c'est l'épiphanie vu leur vous
venez peut-être chez vous de trouver la
fête de minnie de lagos en père m'a
rejoint pour faire le point sur notre
opération sos village on en revient à
notre opération sos village avec vous ou
dominique la grosse en terre bonjour mon
nom mais où dominique dites nous combien
d'annonce au compteur alerter pendant ce
temps là la bourse de paris 45 ans après
est en baisse c'est l'heure qu'il est on
bref un mois de la bourse elle est en
baisse - 0,9 pour cent d'après midi à
demain je souhaite un très bon après
midi et je vous dis à demain
avouez quelqu'un beaucoup plus sympa que
moi je regarde le jt de 13h ou pas déjà
quand c'est lui je regardais pas tout le
temps donc là quand je suis à la maison
bien sûr c'est celle que je vais
regarder et non non j'ai déjà trouvé un
jour regarde avec plaisir parce que
c'est je le dis dans le joint il ya un
membre de la faible c'est une famille le
trésor fait un groupe et il ya un membre
de la famille qui s'en va quelqu'un
d'autre karim et c'est toute l'équipe du
journal qui est là les correspondants en
région sur les mêmes et ils mettent
toute leur passion pour marie sophie
avec my se fixe et formidablement
intégrée elle va pas bouleverser tout
tout de suite elle va faire évoluer le
journal le veulent moderniser sans doute
un petit peu elle moi je le regarde en
tout cas avec beaucoup de plaisir